welcome to the hugging face task series  in this video we'll take a look at the  causal language modeling  causal language modeling is the task of  predicting the next word in a sentence  given all the previous words  this task is very similar to the  autocorrect function that you might have  on your  phone these models take a sequence to be  completed and outputs to complete  sequence  classification metrics can't be used as  there is no single correct answer for  the compilation  instead we evaluate the distribution of  the text completed by the model  a common metric to do so is the  cross-entropy loss  perplexity is also widely used metric  and it is calculated as the exponential  of the cross-entropy loss  you can use any data set with plain text  and tokenize the text to prepare the  data  causal language models can be used to  generate code  for more information about the causal  language modeling task check out the  hugging face course